[Music]
and out-of-this-world news
inside of the world submitted by weird
hours like what that's like me right now
did you guys wake up refreshed because
we gave in that hour here yeah yeah I
love this [ __ ] away from us dude it's so
[ __ ] petitioning I think government to
trying to take away daylight saving cuz
what was the perp it was like some
farming [ __ ] right yeah yeah just keep
it the same like a farmer to do that I
think we're the only country that
doesn't yeah but it's fun banks don't
have daylight savings yeah I mean Hawaii
and it's either New Mexico or Arizona or
whatever they're in the future they're
living in the future Harvard researchers
say the mystery object that sped past
Earth last year could be a probe sent by
aliens Harvard researchers say that this
is a really new Harvard middle can you
pick that [ __ ] because that [ __ ] made me
go what the hell Harvard researchers say
the mystery object that sped past earth
last year could be a probe sent by
aliens I mean really so it's not a
meteor no they thought it was a comet or
an asteroid but now they're suggesting
that this might be something familiar
those are the shape size and the way
that it accelerated I'm curious why
didn't it [ __ ] stop by that looks
like a Dookie that's not what it is
that's us that's somebody art that's
about cup yeah that looks tight though
right looks like it came from Superman's
planet you know what it looks like it
looks like a native Arrowhead why can't
they look prettier and more colorful
quite I got it look we did report those
reddish but the this photos memorize
that looks like a flying piece of [ __ ]
why not make it pretty like his
outerspace ugly looks like a Cheeto just
flying in the air tomorrow log it's
nicknamed omama
which is
that sounds like some alien time it's
Hawaiian it's Hawaiian
oh yeah
good luck Hawaiian food no it's the way
she said it I circle she's like a collie
way that's why I [ __ ] it up a
messenger that reaches out from the
distant past in Hawaiian that's what
that means fall and so it was first
discovered Hite trying to save my own
ass nice yeah that sounds great I love
white sounds awesome I love the coconut
drinks I love every thank you so I was
discovered back in October of last year
by a telescope in Hawaii and so now
there's this new paper by researchers at
the harvard-smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics that suggests that this was
maybe a fully operational probe sent
intentionally to Earth's vicinity by an
alien civilization I love how it took
him a year to figure this out like hey
that's actually a [ __ ] probe instead
of like looking at it and going well
they they were studying it for three
days when it was around yeah and so then
they I guess it took them all this time
to figure out this ship so they're
saying that is possibly a light sail
that is floating in interstellar space
as a debris from an advanced
technological equipment the idea behind
the light sails like you have a craft
and you project it through the universe
using light Wow pretty cool tells it you
don't like we have created yes things
like that we know this one that that's
going to Mars right now with that
[ __ ] umbrella it's like a solar
umbrella so this was the trajectory here
of this alien thing so what's weird is I
mean obviously it turned yeah but then
it also accelerated like it did in kind
of what it needed to get all right got
that gravity whip it out isn't that a
possibility to saying that the Sun the
light
when the Sun was what propelled it like
crazy so is it saying that the
acceleration shows that it's not just
like a cosmic body that it's actually
some alien tech that's one of this one
of the theories right that's why it took
a year because it's like they're dirt
testing many different because it could
just be like that boomerang where that
the gravity and everything pushes and
pulls yeah like what we did dis Ling
Shan around the moon like an Apollo all
the Apollo's yeah yeah so they're saying
that the usual trajectory the high speed
what the bumper stickers say on the
thing they could read because the
telescope was so far no damn I wonder
how long it took to like get close to
Earth and and wrap around and shoot back
out like like if it was like one day or
like could that must be going fast as
food this is the first object ever seen
in our solar system that is known to
have originated somewhere else damn
that's tight I don't want any aliens to
come they're already here bro but I
don't want them to expose themselves I
want to I want them to stay underground
why it's like vampires I want them to
stay underground what are the aliens
that could be that's cool but I wouldn't
want to know cuz I just one of them why
do you want it why do you want to keep
them a secret
I just want to chill what if they're
awesome because like literally like
we're just exactly the way we look and
stuff but we wouldn't you guys already
hate people why would you want more
people we wouldn't flying something that
[ __ ] ugly alright so this is like a
snail go like a part of a bigger probe
yeah it's like how we sent the Voyager
craft and this space is like why this is
some ugly shitty thing and not a person
right it's the same idea it's like it's
it's what I'm still with that like why
didn't add more color and make it pretty
you're not wrong make sure the color did
a little bit but but did red dark red no
no the Voyager probes she took she
talked to Sean the boy they're so smart
I don't care about style anymore I guess
all right the only thing I want them to
do if they do expose anything is I want
them to come out and then they're like
10 feet 11 feet tall or whatever and
they go who's skinny ancient aliens it's
real [ __ ] and because like we
saw the History Channel we know you guys
are ready you know that would be tennis
like thanks Terrence dude yeah I was
like thanks cuz that's been killing me
for a while I was wondering who [ __ ]
built that [ __ ] only reason why they
come out of hiding is just to confirm
that yeah and then they go back to
promotion for the new in season agent
yeah they'll be doh yeah I feel like the
more plausible thing is that we're
aliens just because I heard that theory
and I was like dude we're so [ __ ]
different from every other like come if
we're that were that I don't think like
another alien taking up on you've seen
what we're doing oh I see see if we if
we strayed from the path of our switch
we look like our distant alien relative
what you wanted now compared to that
dude we used to be blowing up nuclear
bombs in our atmosphere and all kind of
[ __ ] what the theory that Sam said that
the moon is like a satellite where the
are viewing us Buzz Aldrin or whatever
they went there and they never went back
after no never that never happened
no no but after Buzz went there we
weren't there like nine more times well
I mean since then all true recently
right the seventies yeah yeah we don't
go there and there's no more Apollo
missions maybe is boring that's what
they said this is hella boring we
figured it up yeah because when Bruce
Willis went he was like that's why we
get it yeah they saw certain things
while they were going to the moon or or
there what do they see they don't see
they usually seen some kind of UFO but
they don't but when you say UFO that
could be anything right
my object could be anything us to go
back to the moon now and then with our
technology and our visual take I want to
see that [ __ ] me too
yeah I don't wanna see these [ __ ]
1970 [ __ ] photos and videos anyway I
want to see us bring those things I'll
hold a six-pack can of cokes the rubber
thing yeah yeah bring like a bunch of
those out there throw it into the round
the mood and see if it catches any
aliens like you bring the alien be like
alien Segal or something gets
[ __ ] and then we could free em
as we know these things are very useful
in caching things they're very good at
catching things what about the aliens
that live in the ocean people think of
things oh they're supposed to be a space
station like a water station in
Antarctica
yeah or inside the inside the oceans I
believe an alien station yeah oh I think
that if you drain the oceans like if you
drain the ocean you'd see all kinds of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah have you seen
they've done that like where they
they'll create like a computer simulator
or whatever what it looks like down
there yeah and then they'll they get rid
of all the water and there's like
volcanoes it's [ __ ] ugly and it's
great yeah Gary looking cool they found
cities ancient cities in the ocean
because our water level used to be lower
yeah they're like I think that we are
definitely not alone I think that it's
stupid to argue that world that the in
the universe we're the only thing that
is alive sure I agree I don't think
we're alone either no there's no way
yeah I just wonder how much intelligent
life there is out there cuz I I think
that like I think about life I don't
think we're that special like I there's
no way that we're so special that were
the aliens cuz I feel special as [ __ ]
right now you're like the only child you
don't know anyone maybe they're
invisible to us and we're invisible to
them too like we just something to see
the same things with the same light like
dirt
like you know like flies they see things
differently than we do or dogs see
things differently interstellar wears
like different dimensions like do
subatomic aliens what if we're like ants
to them so when they come here they're
like but these cockroaches yeah it's
like a common thing in pop culture worth
yeah we're in in sci-fi where it's like
we're in a snow globe on some aliens
desk yeah yep pretty cool die there's
proof that is wild no trippy we're like
a alien kids [ __ ] like science mold
project and what if it's the opposite
and it's just like there's really
nothing there we you see the smoke some
[ __ ] weed right now and then I think
this conversation would be quite stone
JK there here's a crazy part you know
when you go like when you zoom in to the
cellular level of things and then you
zoom out to the space level of things
yeah like if you see like an iris of
someone's eyeball and then you see like
a galaxy or whatever it looks the same
and [ __ ] that's some [ __ ]
mind-blowing [ __ ] yeah and who's to say
that we're not in an artificial
artificially created program ie llamas
beliefs so put a lot of your attributes
into one area on the character create
hey you could sing and you're funny but
then you accident-prone accident-prone I
break my [ __ ] a lot yep you got very
attractive friends there you go you give
great hugs oh I guess it's not you David
nothing losing that yeah I want to be a
great hugger yes I want to be a more
injury-prone if I can get some pretty
good hugs in yeah survival skills zero
what bars completely empty dude so she's
killed your ass too Jumanji you're on
one of her characters and then you can
see the [ __ ] theme it's like very
accident-prone and he just died on the
spot died on the spot I know too bad I
have unlimited lives for some reason
continually I know you feel like this is
this is how it went down okay we're
either one a game or this is how we
figured out how we can keep our soul
alive so it's like how can you keep your
if you realize that you exist and you
want infinite numbers of lives how can
you keep that like
you know how pink make that happen if in
the physical realm that's impossible
because in the physical realm everything
has to die renew right but then if you
can figure out how to create a system
throw your soul in that system and they
could reborn over and over and over
again and then how you keep them busy is
letting them go through different
scenarios constantly then you then you
can have infinite lives and the further
that you get on the subatomic level like
you see in consistencies and the laws
that supposedly govern our it's like
with gravity with reality like you can
see atoms like appearing and
disappearing and trend teleporting in
different spaces so maybe we're all in a
game and like we're we're not supposed
to go that deep beyond the boundaries
yeah or it's like like like in Grand
Theft Auto when you go to a certain part
of the ocean like you hit an invisible
wall and then you experiment with the
with the atoms or particles were they
like what if if it was being observed
then the outcome was different versus if
it was observed exactly and it didn't
exist when it was unobserved how [ __ ]
weird is that and by the way that's what
video games do when you're facing
something it's generating that content
and when you're facing away from it it's
it's taking a well same exact idea we're
in a [ __ ] program but humans are
powerful because we can control the
program if you tap into that now that's
gonna [ __ ] blow your mind
that's [ __ ] matrix right there hell
yeah
we're neo all of us are neo come we
can't fly though that enlightenment
no it's more like controlling your
reality through perception and then
controlling your outcomes through dude
let's just die yeah I don't know I was
fat too last year
[Laughter]
[Music]